tag danach der schock sitzt weiter tief
bei uns in der ganzen bildredaktion hier
im haus in unsere reporter sind
beschossen worden im kriegseinsatz paul
ronzheimer und sein team
mehr als vier monaten in der ukraine und
nun das
dann hören sie die einschläge sie sehen
wie paul ronzheimer sich dort wie das
auto weiteres passiert ist das alles in
musik tanz
nach einer attacke
schlägt hinten ins auto rein ein teil
von einem geschoss durchlöchert die
scheibe einen halben meter entfernt von
paul
passiert im lied chance beziehungsweise
auf dem weg raus aus diesem ort dort
ganz in der ost ukraine paul war dorthin
gefahren sie sehen das noch mal auf der
karte mit seinem team weil er wusste
dass dort in diesem krieg gerade eine
ganz wichtige front verläuft dass die
russen dabei sind diese stadt
einzukesseln der wusste dass es sie
besonders gefährlich sein wird dort er
hatte uns vor seinem weg in die stadt
noch geschrieben dass es ein heikler
tritt wird handy erst mal aus wir melden
uns wenn wir hier daraus sind ja und
dann passierte eben das
das sind die sekunden die zeigen wie
unbarmherzig die russischen truppen
vorgehen
[Applaus]
alles schießen eben auch auf unser
reporter-team die sekunden die die welt
die unser kanzler sehen muss um diesen
krieg auch nach vier monaten nicht zu
vergessen schauen sie das geschockte
gesicht von paul und die sekunden waren
das nach dem wir einfach nur dankbar
sind dass paul lebt
straße ist wahrscheinlich die
gefährlichste
und es in der ukraine gerade gibt
rückblick mittwochmorgen paul ronzheimer
berichtet aus kammerforst kündigt an am
nachmittag in die eingekesselte
stadtmusikanten zu reisen tja die reise
dorthin du hast es angesprochen ist
schwierig ist kompliziert und ist
wahnsinnig gefährlich denn es gibt nur
noch wenige straßen dorthin führen
vertreter man muss sich das so
vorstellen
die russen haben vor diesen bereich
komplett einzukesseln also komplett
einzuschließen um dann die ukrainische
armee dort stellen zu können zur aufgabe
zu zwingen oder dort alle zu töten paul
ronzheimer und sein team gelangen sicher
bis nachlässig chance gegen mittag
drehten sie den rückweg an sie müssen
die stadt auf der einzigen freien straße
verlassen der road to hell wie sie unter
ukraine heißt der straße zur hölle die
russische armee schießt dort auf alles
was sich bewegt dann nur wenige
kilometer außerhalb von
explosionen
das muss höchstens 100 oder 150 meter
weit weg gewesen sein in den feldern
gerade
unser auto beschossen worden
straße ist wahrscheinlich die
gefährlichste und in der ukraine gerade
gibt so schnell wie möglich raus das
bild team über eine staubige straße
versucht den explosionen zu entkommen
das ist sie die straße zur hölle doch
dann explosionen in unmittelbarer nähe
das auto wird getroffen eine scheibe
geht zu bruch nur das fenster was von
erwischt worden ist
die russen schießen hier diesen weg war
das der einzige weg raus ist aus der
stadt
erst nach gut einer halben stunde fahrt
kann das bild team die straße zur hölle
verlassen sind die explosionen nicht
mehr zu hören wie durch ein wunder wird
niemand verletzt
die straße zur hölle erst vor wenigen
monaten ist hier ein französischer
reporter umgekommen fast zwei dutzend
reporter starben bislang im ukraine
krieg
und jetzt ist er bei uns haben wir sind
wahnsinnig froh dich zu sehen an diesem
morgen an diesem morgen danach bei dem
auch bei uns diese bilder wirklich noch
sacken und die freude mal größer wird
dich zu sehen der schock aber auch noch
ganz tief in den knochen sitzt wie geht
es euch wie geht es deinem team wie
geht's georgius eine ganz junger vater
ist ein baby erst ein paar wochen alt
wie geht es war ihm geht es euch an
diesem morgen
er vertritt ja wir sind gestern nacht
noch aus dem don dass sie nachts micro
gefahren das war uns wichtig da erstmal
einmal rauszukommen zumindest für ein
bisschen und wir haben uns alle umarmt
nachdem wir aus dem gebiet rausfahren
und
uns ist erst abends in der nacht als wir
dann zusammen saßen und wodka getrunken
haben um das ganze irgendwie verarbeiten
zu können
klar geworden dass die wm ist eigentlich
war wie knapp es eigentlich war weil es
so für uns alle natürlich ging es darum
die geschichten die sie ganz zu erzählen
aber dann auch dort raus zu kommen und
eben zu versuchen
ja und dann realisiert zu haben wie
knapp es am ende war für uns alle aber
es ist ein gutes gefühl noch am leben zu
sein sehr gutes gefühl dich so zu sehen
paul ihr seid da rausgekommen zum glück
aus lizenz ganz viele menschen sind drin
in der stadt das war der grund weswegen
ihr dorthin gefahren seid um zu zeigen
wie es den menschen dort geht beschreibt
uns genau das
ja wenn man noch reinkommen nach wie sie
an square waren fast vier stunden dort
in dieser stadt kommen dort vorbei an
einem checkpoint im ersten völlig
verwaist zerstört wir dachten erst dass
der schon ein paar wochen so aussieht
aber in wahrheit wurde er an dem tag als
wir dort rein gefahren sind zerstört und
ein wenn getroffen von sascha und jelena
die wollten humanitäre sachen dort
reinbringen nahrung wasser medizin und
wurden dann ebenfalls angegriffen sie
konnten dort entkommen aber man sieht
dieser werden komplett zerstört dann
sind wir weiter in die stadt und die
menschen
verzweifelt frauen die auf uns
zugekommen sind die geweint haben sie
gesagt haben wir haben hier nichts mehr
werden nicht mal mehr wasser dann sind
sie zu einem feuerwehrauto dort gab es
dann wasser für sie die meisten leben
die ganze zeit im keller auch dort waren
wir mit einem priester gesprochen
ja und die menschen sind wütend auf die
ukrainische regierung sie sagen sie
kriegen nicht genügend hilfe
auf dem weg dort auf den straßen
plötzlichen ukrainischer soldat vor
eurem auto der möchte dass er
mitgenommen wird von euch erzählt uns
die geschichte
[Applaus]
wir sind dann raus aus dem dom bass und
man muss oft an checkpoints vorbei und
dort stand dann dieser junge mann 29 und
sagte kann ich mit durchfahren kann ich
in euer auto wir haben einen platz frei
auf der seite die gerade beschossen
wurde dieses fenster das kaputte was ich
dort gesehen habt und wir haben
natürlich wirklich mitnehmen wohin
musste warum musste ihr weg er sagt mein
bruder ist gefallen an der front und ich
muss zur beerdigung und er hat jetzt
fünf tage die er bei seiner familie
verbringen darf dazu
bei der beerdigung dabei zu sein und
dann fünf tage später geht er wieder an
die front das ist der alltag hier in der
ukraine
das was dir in deinem team passiert ist
diese sekunden diese momente in denen
man nicht weiß wird das jetzt gut gehen
oder war es das jetzt das passiert dort
in diesem krieg tagtäglich und diese
szenen hat haben uns ja auch diesen
krieg noch einmal so viel näher gebracht
diesen horror diesen schrecken es geht
eher in einem vor in diesen sekunden
ehrlicherweise patricia man denkt es
kann jetzt vorbei sein
wir alle dachten das könnte jetzt der
letzte moment seien nur hörst die ersten
explosionen und du weißt ja wenn es eine
explosion gibt dann geht das weiter die
russen haben so viele waffen so viel
munition dass sie feuern können nun ende
und ich bin dann ja wie aus dem affekt
sozusagen auf den bauch auf dieser
rückbank weil ich mich daran erinnert
habe wie ein kollege gestorben ist da
ist nämlich das ging mir durch den kopf
in diesem moment da ist diese schrapnell
also von der von der explosion hier in
den hals und
deswegen bin ich runter wenn man sich
das video nochmal anschaut sieht man
auch wie knapp ist uns verfehlt hat
daran euro für dein kriegseinsatz dort
den du machst um der welt diese bilder
zu zeigen uns allen hier in deutschland
damit wir auch nach ja mittlerweile mehr
als vier monaten nicht vergessen wie
schrecklich putins angriffskrieg dort
tobt im moment